die messdaten des australischen
radioteleskops experimente global adview
ionisation ages sind wirklich mehr als
mysteriös denn sie widersprechen einfach
voll und ganz dem bild das wir von
unserem universum haben doch ein
internationales forschungsteam hat jetzt
eine äußerst spannende hypothese
aufgestellt mit der diese messdaten
eigentlich ganz prima erklärt werden
können
dabei berufen sie sich auf dunkle
photonen also dunkle lichtteilchen
bisschen paradox das ganze könnte wenn
nicht sogar das standardmodell der
teilchenphysik erweitern
alle wichtigen infos zu der ganzen sache
kommt er jetzt bei pixum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
alles im universum ist irgendwie dunkel
fangen wir an mit der sogenannten
dunklen materie
rund 80 prozent der materie im universum
besteht wohl daraus ein stoff den noch
nie jemand gesehen hat ja es halt dunkel
mit verschiedenen methoden versuchen
forschungsteams weltweit herauszufinden
was hinter der dunklen materie stecken
direkt kann man sie sehen und zwar durch
ihre auswirkungen auf die schwerkraft
schätzung zufolge macht sie wohl knapp
27 prozent der energiedichte des
weltalls auf die sogenannte marianische
materie dagegen was der alles uns
bekannte besteht macht dagegen nur fünf
prozent aus kurz gesagt die dunkle
materie ist so etwas wie der heilige
gral der physik dazu kommt dem universum
wohl auch noch die geheimnisvolle dunkle
energie schon wieder dunkel über die wir
ja auch schon öfter berichtet haben
forschungsteams weltweit verstehen sie
auch noch nicht wirklich doch sie agiert
wohl wie eine art anti schwerkraft die
das universum auseinandertreibt zudem
wird sie wohl umso größer je mehr sich
der raum ausdehnen
das war es aber noch nicht flüssig
aktiven vermuten dem universum neben der
dunklen materie und der dunklen
die auch noch so genannte dunkle
photonen also dunkle lichtteilchen ein
wenig paradox dunkles licht im gegensatz
zu den konventionellen photonen also den
leuchtenden lichtteilchen haben sie in
der vorstellung der fachleute eine masse
und während ihnen direkt nachweisbar und
zwar durch ihren zerfall in elektronen
und positronen also den antiteilchen der
elektronen auch die dunklen photonen
sollen nach ansicht mancher
forschungsteams eine kraft tragen eine
uns bislang völlig unbekannte naturkraft
ihre existenz wurde darauf schließen
lassen dass ein verborgener sektor
existiert der unter anderem auch
teilchen der dunklen materie enthalten
könnte
in diesem zusammenhang haben jetzt
messdaten des australischen
radioteleskop experiment zur detektion
obel epoche ionisation ages für eine
riesige überraschung gesorgt das
internationale forschungsteam hatte
eigentlich das ziel neue modelle zur
dunkle materie zu testen
dabei griffen die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler auf die sogenannte
21 zentimeter kosmologie zurück denn
hiermit kann man erkenntnisse zur
frühzeit des universums gewinnen und das
ist der kosmische hintergrund 200
millionen jahre nach dem urknall haben
sich wohl die ersten sterne gebildet und
für neues licht im universum gesorgt
doch die damals beteiligten
himmelskörper die sind heutzutage mit
teleskopen nicht mehr direkt zu
beobachten doch das riecht damals hat
wohl mit wasserstoff reagiert und somit
eine charakteristische struktur im
spektrum der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung hinterlassen und
diese ist auch heute noch zu beobachten
und zwar bei einer wellenlänge von 21
zentimetern daher auch der name 21
zentimeter kosmologie dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher aus österreich
josef radler die 21 zentimeter kostenlos
die hat das potenzial um neue modelle
der dunkle materie zu testen doch die
messdaten des teleskops zeigen dass das
21 cm signal deutlich vom erwarteten
wert
abweicht daraus schließt das
forschungsteam das höchstwahrscheinlich
eine wechselwirkung mit dunkler materie
stattgefunden haben muss eine erklärung
für den nun gemessenen effekt könnte
sein dass in der frühzeit des universums
mehr lichtteilchen am start gewesen sein
könnten als man bislang angenommen hatte
konkret gehen die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler davon aus dass sich
dunkle photonen in herkömmliche
lichtteilchen verwandelt haben genau das
könnte dann die unerwartete stärke des
gemessenen signals erklären diese
hypothese des forschungsteams basiert
auf der vermutung dass sich dunkle
photonen unter bestimmten umständen in
normale photonen umfallen könnten dazu
bradler unsere theorie beruht auf der
annahme und dunkler photon die nur eine
minimale erweiterung des standardmodells
darstellen jedenfalls ist eines klar die
entdeckung dunkler photonen wäre eine
wahre sensation und vergleichbar mit der
entdeckung der monde um den planeten
jupiter durch galileo die einmal ein
theoretischer physiker aus princeton
betont hatte wenn er kein video dazu und
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann abonniert am besten auch kriegs um
science-fiction auf englisch da gibt es
nämlich manchmal themen auch zuerst
dafür hier klicken aber nicht die glocke
vergessen und dann runter geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken
geheimnisvolles teilchen entdeckt
mysteriöse vorgänge in der antarktis bis
dann bleibt dran